Mikl: We're going to go through some sets of photos about particular iconic aspects of San Francisco.
Mikl: Anyone want to guess what this section is about?
Fred Lyon: this is the photographer's friend.
Fred: Fog is so important.
It is our identifying natural effect.
It covers up works of man that need covering up.
And then there are a few things that you can actually manipulate and use for your own usefulness.
Unfortunately it's not something...
Actually somebody now makes a little bug bomb...
a [portable] fog that you can use.
I have one but I haven't ever used it.
It probably doesn't work anymore.
This is out at Fort Point. (Not far from here)
Mikl: We have a Fort Point beer on tap.
Fred Lyon: That's looking into the Sunset.
Fred Lyon: There's a little backstory to this.
I was doing a story on San Francisco
for some magazine.
And I had a phone call that morning from the magazine.
They said "Fred, we're trying to close this story but we don't have the fog picture yet that you promised."
I said, look you can't just cue the fog when you need it.
I'll get it to you soon. He said, well if it doesn't get
here soon we'll have to do the story without it.
And that evening my bride and I
were invited upstairs to our landlord's
who was going to pour us a cocktail.
And when I was up there he was just about to pour
and I looked out the window....
I could see this string of fog coming.
And we lived in Sausalito at the time.
I said, Oh! Don't pour. He said, "What?!"
They're ready. And I said, I promise you I'll buy you a drink the moment we finish taking this picture.
But we have to go right now.
So we rushed out there.
That's just above where Sutro Baths was.
That is my landlord and my bride and my uncle's car.
While it looks very romantic,
I'm so glad there's no recording of it.
Because they were saying
"Fred, for chrissakes, take the picture!
We're freezing our buns and we're dying of thirst!"
And I'd say, just one more exposure.
I had to take them immediately to the nearest bar.
It was a very expensive production.
Mikl: But that you made your deadline?
Fred: Made the deadline. And actually
we didn't print it again for another 50 or 60 years.
Mikl: But now it's in your San Francisco Noir book.
Fred: Now it's in the book.
Mikl:  We'll get to the book in a minute.
Mikl: So then, there's this guy...
Mr. Herb Caen.
Mikl: Herb Caen... just to get our our facts right here
Mikl: He started in the 1930s; writing
first in Sacramento, then here?
Mikl: Does that sound right?
Fred: Yeah, he was in Sacramento.
Fred: And he was known as the 'Sacamenna Kid'.
Fred: He appeared here and was an instant success.
Herb was unique in that he really got San Francisco.
He did a column that was like no other.
Nobody has been successful in trying to do that again.
I was always irritated with people who said, "Well Herb when are you gonna write something serious?"
To me this [his column] was a great accomplishment.
Mikl: It's hard to explain to someone.
In a way it's like...
Mikl: when there were 3 TV networks, and everybody watched Walter Cronkite. That kind of thing...
Mikl: But for San Francisco, there was Herb Caen.
I don't know that most cities ever even had that kind of
a singular voice that kind of represented the city
in that way. Is that what you would say from being here?
Fred: I would say that was true. And he really loved it.
Mikl: And let's characterize it for folks
who never saw the column...
Mikl: First of all for 60 years basically he was writing for The Chronicle and briefly for The Examiner.
Fred: Right. And there were times when
I would be going through my desk,
Fred: and I would find a snap that I'd done of him.
And I would throw it in the mail to him.
Then once at a party he said:
Hey Fredo, would you do me a great favor?
I said, sure Herb, what?
Please don't send me any more pictures
of me when I had hair?
He went through a period
when he had electric hair that did everything.
And then then he went through a period
when he didn't have enough hair.
But he was he was out on the  town all the time.
And when he went to the Examiner
I asked his replacement at the Chronicle
how it was to try to write Herb Caen's column
And he said, It's no hope there are only so many
talking lawyers and talking doctors in this town.
And Herb's got them all sewed up.
Herb had a roll of 3 x 5 cards; that were a perforated roll.
And they were in his trusty Royal [typewriter].
Whenever the phone would ring, he or his assistant would take whatever came in.
And if it sounded like something promising they would type it on that. And it would go into a little card file.
And when it came time to put together a column
Herb would go through that and rephrase it
in "three dot journalism" as he called it.
Mikl: We can't fully characterize it here, but
he started in the 1930s he was writing until the 1990s.
He was writing columns six days a week
(and then ultimately down to 3 each week).
But they were these little, in a way like
a kind of (proto) Twitter thread...
little chunks of [news/gossip /stories]
as you said from those index cards...
It's things that are happening, tips or gossip,
How would you characterize what he was writing?
Fred: Well, they were wonderful little squibs that
he had adjusted to to make them really zing.
Fred: If you fed stuff to him regularly,
every once in a while he would mention your name.
And that was a great thing.
I found that my UPS man
would always ask me when he came to the door,
How's your buddy Herb?
And I thought, my god, everybody does read this thing.